the greatest genocide
in modern times after world war ii in
europe
they committed the worst single
atrocities seen in europe since the
second world war
you probably haven't heard about now
what all these you have in common
they were practicing orthodox christians
but do we blame christianity for these
evil lunatics no bosnian muslim men and
boys
were selected for murder not only on
account of their muslim
faith but also because of their gender
and bosnian people never thought that a
yugoslavian army will
commit these crimes that they did they
believed in their army and they
supported the army and people served in
the in the army and they were proud
to serve the army so they never thought
never imagined that this army will
commit the crimes that
this army did the women suffered a
different fate
srebrenica was the culmination of a
brutal campaign of ethnic cleansing
across bosnia herzegovina in which 20 to
50
000 women and girls were victims of
genocidal rape
wise and you know within the last year
before conflict
broke in in bosnia they took around and
they took all the weapons from uh
from uh people that they had you know uh
so they basically ended up with no
weapons except some hunting guns and
some uh little pistols and things like
that fighting this
you know what muhammad said this things
this this nationalism
right and this extreme version of it
that actually led them
to go ahead and commit this genocide to
want to wipe the whole
uh muslim bosnian community off the map
they
made plans and they organized uh
this genocide in bosnia and
their main thing was to eliminate
muslims from certain air from certain
areas in bosnia especially in the
eastern bosnia
never forget cerberus is that what is
where over 8 000 people died
and they were supposed to be safe by the
peacekeepers the u.n was there
but right on their watch all these
8 000 plus innocent human beings were
were
systematically massacred is that right
and in july that year
they committed the worst single
atrocities seen in europe since the
second world war
the greek orthodox church described him
as quote
one of the most prominent sons of our
lord jesus christ working for peace
but you never really hear do you have
you heard you don't hear much
connection back in the media
or through any of the news reports um
saying that these are radical christians
it's kind of like what you do as soon as
someone's a muslim
you know islam is on the witness stand
you know it's it's a
it's it's a showcase like this is islam
motivating them
and whatnot but you don't have you heard
that ever
the contrast being made no i i never
heard uh
christian terrorists uh it is usually uh
islamic or muslim terrorists and
first of all there is no islamic
terrorism or islamic terrorists because
islam does not teach terrorism
it teaches peace and coexistence and
tolerance
because obviously if we're going to play
that game they were practicing a form of
radical christianity but we don't blame
christianity right
this is as radical because you have
footage right now people are saying you
know they're in the church
right you know with the po with the
priest sitting and
this is like a crusade this was like
almost one can say this is a modern day
holy what people they would say there's
no such thing as a holy war but to these
people this was a holy war to
exterminate muslims
these people know man they they were
being unprovoked and they were
doing uh you know uh crimes and trying
to
eliminate muslims from from most of the
parts of the bus
worship muslims are not you know
jesus is not worshiping himself now he
was teaching
his followers to worship god who created
him yeah revisiting this history so we
can
prevent god willing through awareness
something tragic like this some evil
like this
happening again